[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Jerome Bettis 2015 Pro Football Hall of
Fame inductee won a Super Bowl with the
Steelers joining us from Atlanta flying
the Notre Dame colors hey we're going to
Dublin for the game against Navy we got
room for you
I know I I just found out I'm I'm gonna
try to make it work unfortunately
um my son's High School football season
starts up so I've got to be a dad and be
in the stands and watch him play
what position does your son play he's a
wide receiver also he's not going to
fall in line and be a running back
because nobody wants to be a running
back anymore yeah he quit he quit me too
I mean I'm just saying the running backs
it's no love I mean my own son but he is
six two and a half so I mean it is
probably not uh in his uh in his
wheelhouse but nobody wants to play
running back anymore okay explain what's
going on in the NFL and how that's
affecting careers here
so let me tell you how it all started it
started because college football went to
a more wide open style of football maybe
let's say about 10 years ago right
everybody started to want to throw the
football around and what happened was
the high schools saw that and then if
you're a high school kid and you want to
go to college you're looking at the
landscape if you were six to 220 pounds
all the colleges wanted small running
backs so you went to linebacker and
instead right so now what what we see
happening after all these years is that
if you don't go to Georgia Alabama uh
Michigan Wisconsin Ohio State you know
you're not going to play running back if
you're 215 220 pounds right so now these
kids The Talented kids are switching
positions and so you don't have that
full range of running backs that you can
go all over the country and get a 6-2
220 pound running back that can that can
give you 25 carries a game those guys
don't exist anymore unless you go to
those five or six colleges right so now
if you're a GM you're saying okay well I
don't have that special running back
that's in the draft this year let me get
two guys three guys that we feel can can
kind of feel that void and be one
running back but be three different
players and so that's what you're seeing
now you're not seeing uh a plethora of
quality running backs but when you do
see them now
these teams have an opportunity to
devalue the position you know a lot of
people say well maybe it's undervalued
you know it's a devaluation of the
position because now they say we don't
have to pay you because we can get them
elsewhere but the truth is when you get
a special running back like I said call
Barkley you can't find them they don't
grow on trees so you you do have to pay
them but because the this this place
that we're at they don't have to justify
to the fans that hey we needed to pay
him top dollar because he was a quality
running back we can afford to play
hardball with them because the market is
dictating that we don't have to pay him
that number and that's just uh it's a
terrible situation but how would that
affect you if you were in high school
of playing that position
because you said yourself one
I don't really I see what's happening
right if I get to the NFL I was probably
not going to be uh very lucrative for me
and two there's not many colleges that
want you if I'm if I'm 225 pounds uh and
I'm six foot I only can go to maybe five
or six schools and play running back so
the
I've got a better shot at playing
linebacker then I can go to 100 Schools
uh and I can be six to 230 pounds as a
linebacker and I can play anywhere so
if I'm in high school it's very limited
where I can go and play did your son
change positions was he a running back
and then became a wide receiver Well he
kind of grew out of the position so he
played okay he played wide receiver the
first year of of little league and then
he uh he went to running back and then
he got too tall and then he he went went
to wide receiver just out of necessity
because you know he was almost six foot
in and all the other kids were you know
five seven five eight but I also wonder
about the middle linebacker position
bossy because you had Brian Urlacher and
you know Ray Lewis I mean go down
through NFL history and it's littered
with great running backs and great
middle linebackers nobody is speaking
out on behalf of middle linebackers that
you know nobody cares about them anymore
but it they are about running backs
yeah it it is what's happened is this
change uh to the passing game has really
eliminated uh it's already totally
eliminated the fullback position that's
that's already totally gone and I think
um you know that was the Peyton Manning
era that really kind of ushered out the
fullback and so now because you know the
the math uh and the numbers say you
throw the football throw the football
and as a result of that everyone's
gotten smaller because now you need to
be more athletic you need to move around
and you need to protect and and all
those kind of things so now you're not
running the ball that much you have to
plan coverage so now my linebacker I
need him to be more of a uh defensive
back and linebacker and so I need him to
be 225 230 maybe 2 40. but he's got to
be extremely fast because I need him now
to cover these tight ends who are no
longer tight ends they're global
receivers and so now the game has
switched because the emphasis used to be
running the football on first and second
down now the emphasis is passing the
ballroom first and second down uh and
it's changed the way these athletes look
now you don't have a 250 pound 260 pound
linebacker you don't have a 320 pound
offense yeah but it's going to change
though busy where a team goes hey you're
about speed and finesse we're going to
be power and you know we saw this with
the Titans and and it's worked for them
but I wonder if you get a team that just
says we're going to be different than
everybody else we don't have a franchise
quarterback we're gonna have a good
offensive line we're going to run the
football we're going to keep you off the
field and we're going to you know play
really good defense
I I think that's the recipe for what
you're going to see in Pittsburgh I
think Kenny Pickett is is going to be a
special quarterback he's still
developing and while he's developing I
think you're going to run the football
you got to run the football so I think
you're still going to see that
philosophy
um quite a bit uh but you have to have
that special running back you know it
it's easy to say we're going to do that
we're going to do that but
um you know King Henry he was he's a
special running back you can do that
around him but you don't have a lot of
those guys out there where you can just
turn it over and say we're going to give
you the ball uh 400 times and you know
they're going to have trouble dealing
with you but but if you do you have a
decided Advantage because most of these
defenses are much smaller than they were
historically I agree uh how many Hall of
Fame Defenders do you think you ran ran
over
oh man
oh boy
I got a few under my belt I do I got a
picture my first year uh and and this is
it's very funny I got a picture we went
and played the New York Giants my rookie
year with the Rams and I got a picture
of Lawrence Taylor
on my leg and I'm kind of dragging them
and it's like the the most incredible
picture because nobody knows he's in his
16th or 17th year and nobody knows he's
40 years old all you see is Lawrence
Taylor in this Giant's helmet and I'm
dragging him so I get to I get to put
that up and I get to lie to everyone and
say that he was in his prime when that
happened
do you know I still have your Rams
jersey that you signed
do you yeah I have I God I you know what
my man cave is so
do you guys know where the Bettis Jersey
is yeah so much stuff I do I do but I
don't know where it is
can you guys bring it out of the
archives you got to bring out the
archives I got it around here busy
um oh you know what it is it's out in
the bullpen it's out by Rob yes if you
guys can bring that out that would be
great uh
I don't know what it's worth can I put
it on eBay you're uh sure you're you're
not gonna be worth a whole lot was that
your St Louis Rams or your LA Rams that
was my LA Rams LA Rams oh that's right
blue and gold
yeah that was that was LA Rams yeah
how many some good times is there a Mark
still on you from getting hit
yeah I um I never forget I played in
Houston uh the Oilers at the time and I
was I was a rookie and I'll never forget
my offensive coordinator told me okay he
drew up this play and he said it's a
goal line play the backside linebacker
is going to be unblocked but it's no
problem right that's what he said to me
well
he didn't tell me that
the backside linebacker could get to the
play in time so I'm thinking that oh
wait a minute hold on there you go oh
that is that's special there yeah you
know I got uh your Rams Rams jersey
behind me that's old school right there
wait do you want I mean do you have this
jersey I do okay all right so then you
don't need it I do absolutely okay all
right all right just want to make sure
I'm nostalgic I always okay I have one
um for all your teams that's right
absolutely okay so explain the play
so so he told me that the backside
Lineback is unblocked no worries you can
still score a touchdown
what he didn't tell me was that that the
guy was going to be able to hit me so
they call this play I'm running and I
promise you I got hit so hard I was
almost out on my feet and he hit me
behind my ear and my earpiece went and
cut into my neck so I still have a uh a
cut around my neck and I I immediately
went right to the sideline and cussed
out my office coordinator
because he he told me that oh don't
worry about him and I was like bull yeah
yeah didn't you didn't you knock out Ed
Reed
then he kind of a blitz no that was um
that was Heinz war that Cartier Reed oh
yeah yeah and they were then they
started chasing him all over the field
they were trying to get back at him they
were trying to get him
uh Rob Woodson was on that team too they
were trying to they were chasing him all
over the field trying to get him just
trying to hurt him purposely purposely
trying to hurt him uh yeah there were a
lot of teams that wanted to purposely
hurt Heinz Warren there was it was right
and that's why that's why he should he
should definitely be in the Hall of Fame
I mean he's one of those great running
wide receivers who could block uh just
as good as he could uh catch it why did
you pick number six
okay good question
so at high school I was number 36 so
when I got to Notre Dame I wanted to
play I wanted 36 and Lou Holtz told me
that
Don Grimm Russ Grimm from the uh
Washington now commanders who was in the
who was in the um
um
office alignment in the Hall of Fame his
younger brother
um Don Grimm had number 36 right he said
he's a senior I can't take a number from
a senior so I said okay well Rick Meyer
had number three
and then you had Dorsey Levins who was
there
um um Rodney Culver had five Dorsey have
four so I said give me six it was either
the three or the six I couldn't get the
three so I said give me the six and
that's how I ended up with six at Notre
Dame would you be okay if Notre Dame
joined the Big Ten
you know what
yeah I would be but I don't think it
would ever happen you know that wasn't I
think I believe there was a time when
they actually reached out to the Big Ten
um but um at the time they were they
weren't a research school and the Big
Ten I I believe if I'm Barack denied
them uh uh entry because they weren't a
research school at the time and they
didn't want to split the research money
with the school that wasn't a research
school and so I think that's kind of
happened uh if my if my math is correct
uh uh but if it happened I wouldn't be I
wouldn't be upset with it at all do you
remember telling me the story about when
Urban Meyer
was thinking about Notre Dame
and he he didn't even stop into South
Bend I think he wanted to get two
players in
to Notre Dame who maybe wouldn't qualify
normally with the academic standards
does that sound right but he wasn't
going to get what Lou holdscott and he
didn't even stop through South Bend he
went straight to Gainesville Florida
yeah is that right I do he yeah he said
um at the time I guess coach hosts the
deal that coach had he could probably I
thought he could get two yeah and he
only wanted one Urban my only wanted one
guy who who from a from a grade point
average might not be uh um at the
highest level and so he wanted one guy
that he could maybe
um have that opportunity to get in they
told him no
and he said well I mean why why would I
find that when I can get 25 in at
Florida uh why would I do that and so
and and it was yeah it really hurt but
it I understood his situation
um but also understood nobody's only
asking for one
but the problem is once you know once
once you get that one uh then
you want more yeah and so he goes from
Utah to Florida
with no stop in South Bend
with no Stoppers out there and and he
said he really really wanted that job
but um he couldn't uh he couldn't do it
so yeah that it hurt the program but I
think we got a really good one now so
let's uh let's keep up maybe I'll see
you in Dublin bring your pxg clubs if
you come over there absolutely I saw
that sweater man I was looking at that
I swear
that sexy Club so the Gen sixes so I'm
looking forward to playing with them
well I know that uh you love your golf
uh busy good to talk to you as always
thank you good luck to your son this
year
thank you appreciate that Jerome Bettis
Hall of Famer take a break last call for
phone calls what we learned what's in
store tomorrow right after this